Thank you. Thank you.
That is the exact right amount
of applause.
You would not believe how many
audiences get that wrong.
I will not disappoint.
I am a feminist and a vegan.
So -- Yeah.
Yeah, so you know my sense
of humor is top-shelf.
Any vegans...?
I don't believe none here.
Maybe too tired to clap.
You have your lentils
early in the day.
You know, you lose some steam.
I love it.
I love being a vegan.
It's no animal
or animal byproduct of any k--
I do eat eggs, because
I'm also pro-choice.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I don't like people
who are too extreme.
You know,
"I'm a vegan, but I hunt."
[ Laughter ]
My friends are like, "Oh,
my God. That's so hypocritical."
"But I don't eat any of it.
I just leave it there.
I don't use any part
of the animal.
So...still holding strong
to my beliefs."
I'm a feminist.
Do we have any feminists here
tonight, by applause?
[ Applause ]
Wow! A lot of single ladies.
[ Laughter ]
No, it's -- it's so hard if
you're on a date to be like,
"Whoo! The future is female!
Are you still gonna
pay for everything?
Is that deal still on the table?
I'm more of a feminist
in the mornings
when nobody's trying
to buy me anything."
Hey, ladies,
maybe we should start paying
for our own dinner and drinks,
you know, really let guys know
we're serious about
this equality thing.
Really --
I'm just kidding around.
Why would we do that? No.
I think it's the responsibility
of a man you just met online
to feed you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
He's got the option
to kill you later,
so I feel like that's fair.
You put in all the risk.
Get a nice meal out of it.
I love the whole
#MeToo Movement.
I just think it's so --
I am lucky.
I've never had any
sexual harassment happen.
I tried to start #MeNeither.
It's never caught on.
You know, I had nobody join up.
[ Laughter ]
The greatest thing about
being a woman is I'm a mom.
And I had a baby.
I'll never forget it.
It was five or ten years ago.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
When my daughter turned 10,
I got her a phone.
And she's always on it.
She just loves her phone.
I don't even know what
she looks like without
a light in her face.
I'll be honest with you.
The other day,
she was reading a book.
I walked right by.
I didn't know who she was.
I was like, "Who is that
with the sepia tones?"
[ Laughter ]
It's so bad for your kids.
They say it's digital heroin.
You know, when I heard that,
I got scared.
I told my daughter --
I tweeted it to her --
I was like,
"Hey, this has got to stop!"
And then she favorited it,
and then we Snapchatted
back and forth about it
a little bit.
I don't remember
those conversations.
And we'll never
have them back, but...
that is the nature of Snapchat.
Parenting is hard.
You have to teach your kids
stuff that you just think
they should already
instinctively know.
Like, the other day,
my daughter and I are
going through the drive-thru
at Dunkin' Donuts.
I go to her,
"Hey, you want a doughnut?"
She goes, "Oh, I'm not
really hungry right now."
I was like, "That's not
how doughnuts work.
What, are you gonna wait
until your stomach growls?
Nobody does that!
This is America.
You eat until your heart
gives out."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I punished my daughter
a few weeks ago.
I took her phone away
for three days
because she was
being mean to Siri.
And the transformation in her
was unbelievable.
Like, yes, the first day, she
just laid on the floor crying,
but once she got over
the shakes, she...
[ Laughter ]
She got up, she looked around,
she started liking things
in real life.
She double-tapped the dog.
[ Laughter ]
She was like,
"Mom, let's go to the park.
Mom, let's go to the library.
Mom, let's play in the creek."
But I just gave her
her phone back.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
So, I'm married,
and this is the sadder part
of the show.
[ Laughter ]
I wish somebody had told me
before I got married
how much yelling I would
have to do on a daily basis.
It's really
an incredible amount of --
If you're not married yet,
start yelling at your boyfriend.
You've got to build
those vocal cords up.
Because in marriage,
there's no better way.
Like, at one point,
I got so mad at my husband,
I gave him the silent treatment
for a week.
At the end of it, he was like,
"We've been getting along
pretty good lately."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much!
Thank you.
♪♪♪♪
-That couldn't have gone
any better. I love you.
Bonnie! Bonnie McFarlane!
Follow her on Twitter --
@BonnieMcFarlane.